well vice-president Mike Pence says he
would take a lie detector test to prove
he isn't the senior administration
official who wrote a New York Times
op-ed about resisting the president
pence told Face the Nation moderator
Margaret Brennan that the author quote
doesn't know what really happens in this
White House so you don't think anyone on
your staff since they're calling himself
the trump appointee had anything to do
with this I just I wouldn't know
and I would I really would hope not and
I was I was heartened to see so many of
our colleagues make it very clear that
they weren't involved in this in any way
well after the interview was finished
the vice president told CBS News he
misunderstood the question and asked if
he could clarify so Margaret continued
her interview mr. vice president I asked
you earlier if anyone on your staff
wrote this op-ed have you asked your
staff oh well I thought you were
speaking about the administration staff
let me be very clear I'm a 100 percent
confident that no one on the vice
president's staff was involved in this
an anonymous editorial and you asked
them well I you know you know honestly I
don't have to ask them because I know
them I know their character I know their
dedication and I'm absolutely confident
that no one on the vice president's
staff had anything to do with this the
vice president says whoever wrote the
op-ed should quote do the honorable
thing and resign